i keith olbermann and this is the
resistance donald trump has declared war
on the legal system moved to overrule
the spirit of the constitution and
enacted a coup against the ideals of the
United States of America and at this
hour
one of two things is already and
irretrievably underway either the end of
Trump or the end of American democracy
because both cannot continue because
simply you cannot fire the man who is
investigating you it is axiomatic it is
simple it is eternal it is proven you
cannot fire the man who is investigating
you even the dumb people will understand
what you are trying to get away with no
matter what excuse you provide no matter
who you get to agree with you no matter
what you think it will accomplish for
you no matter what you think it will
protect you from no matter if you are
the president of the United States and
the man you have fired might be guilty
of something you cannot fire the man who
is investigating you to do so is to
inherit the wind to do so is to
immediately and irreversibly take
whatever problems you face whatever
investigations you have to suffer
whatever crimes you may or may not have
already committed and to magnify and
multiply them by a number so large it
almost cannot be counted you cannot fire
the man who is investigating you it is
by itself a cover-up not just part of an
already extant cover-up
not another drop in a bucket of
corruption and dishonesty it is an
entirely new bucket Donald Trump fired
the man who was investigating him that
by itself without further explanation
without further evidence that alone
immediately is a cover-up Donald Trump
should be impeached as president today
or this one Act no Russian collusion
needs now to be proved no financial
records need to be assayed no Michael
Flynn no Carter page no Paul Manafort no
ambassador kiss lyac no steel dossier no
trump tapes no Eric Trump tapes no pen
tapes no hacking no sanity hearing no
hundred-million-dollar golf course
dollars from Russia no last-minute Comey
requests for a larger Russian
investigation budget you cannot fire the
man who is investigating you Trump is
effectively guilty today of an
impeachable offense and if enough of the
Republican members of the House and
Senate are anything other than political
[ __ ] and the fully owned lickspittles
of corporations and other special
interests Trump will be impeached within
two hours of Trump's strategically
inexplicable blunder the Republican
congressman Justin Amash of Michigan
tweeted my staff and I are reviewing
legislation to establish an independent
commission on Russia the second
paragraph of this letter is bizarre
Amash referred to this in trump's
dismissal notice to James Comey while I
greatly appreciate you informing me on
three separate occasions that I am NOT
under investigation I nevertheless
concur bizarre is an understatement
this is suicidal Trump simply says I am
NOT under investigation he never
mentions under investigation for what
further there is no evidence Comey ever
told him anything of the sort or that
Comey made a distinction to him between
an investigation of his campaign and of
him personally James Comey testified
last week that the FBI is coordinating
with two prosecutors one at the
Department of Justice and one being the
US Attorney for the Eastern District of
Virginia in their investigations of
possible collusion between trumps
campaign team and the Russian government
the non mainstream observer Claude
Taylor had claimed there was already a
Trump Russia grand jury sitting near
Washington and CNN reported on Tuesday
night that indeed there was a grand jury
in Alexandria Virginia and that it had
issued subpoenas to Associates of
Michael Flynn quote in recent weeks it
is fair to assume that some part of that
news was what got James Comey fired
whether or not in his hazy grasp of
reality Trump really thought he could
somehow put the Russian toothpaste back
into the FBI - he clearly thought CN
reported this Tuesday night he clearly
thought there would be no political
blowback Trump's ham-handed falsely
lighthearted tweets Wednesday morning
about when things calm down and how
Republican and Democrat alike will be
thanking him confirm this his next round
of tweets criticizing the Vietnam
Service controversy of a little-known
senator without remembering that that
would also invoke his own five
deferments from Vietnam confirmed the
mixture of rage and panic that had been
reported earlier that he had raged over
how much television coverage Comey was
getting and that he had been screaming
at television coverage of his Russian
scandal and commis refusal to make it
all disappear at minimum somebody told
this unstable president where he told
himself that any fallout would be less
damaging to him than would be letting
Comey proceed this is not true because
of the simplicity of the only takeaway
from this naked power grab you cannot
fire the man who is investigating you so
we have a Tuesday night Massacre for our
times and for those of you who always
wondered what it felt like to live
through Watergate welcome that catch in
the throat that intake of breath that
does not go all the way through that
repeated sensation that the future of
the democracy in this country rests not
on the events of an administration or a
year nor a month but rests on those of
the next few weeks
that is what October 20th 1973 felt like
Richard Nixon had been able to get a new
Attorney General approved by the
Democratic Senate only when that
attorney general Elliot Richardson swore
to name a special Watergate prosecutor
on Saturday October 20th 1973 Nixon
decided that the prosecutor Archibald
Cox had to be fired the Attorney General
would not do it and resigned instead the
Deputy Attorney General would not do it
Nixon fired him the third man at the
Justice Department the Solicitor General
he fired Cox when the sun rose that
beautiful Saturday morning Richard Nixon
may have had enough political capital
enough House and Senate support enough
public approval
who survived when the Sun rose the next
morning most of that was gone
politically he was a dead man walking
because you cannot fire the man who was
investigating you Republican
representatives Amash Comstock of
Virginia Kibeho of Florida and Senators
burr corker flake and McCain had by
breakfast made correct and patriotic
responses to the crisis nevertheless it
may require still more evil from Trump
to shake the remaining disloyal or
disbelieving Republican political [ __ ]
loose from the tree but if the Comey
firing does not do that sadly Trump will
provide that evil at some point and even
Republicans will then abandon him but
will they abandon him in time you cannot
fire the man who is investigating you
because the next man will now also have
to investigate you for that whether ours
shall continue to be a government of
laws and not of men read the entirety of
Archie Cox's statement after Nixon fired
him in 1973 is now for Congress and
ultimately the American people resist
peace